My name is Wade Watts. My dad picked that name because it sounded like a superhero's alter-ego.
Like Peter Parker or Bruce Banner.
But he died when I was a kid. My mom, too.
And I ended up here.
Sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere. There's nowhere left to go.
Nowhere...
Except the Oasis.
A whole virtual universe
(Depeche Mode) ♪ Let me take you on a train ♪
♪ Around the world and back ♪
People come to the Oasis for all the things they can do
♪ And you won't have to move, you just sit still ♪
But they stay because of all the things they can be.
Art3mis: Can you feel this?
Parzival: Um... Yeah.
It's the only place that feels like I mean anything.
The Oasis was the brainchild of James Halliday.
Hello. If you're watching this I'm dead.
I created a hidden object, an Easter Egg. The first person to find the Egg will inherit half a trillion dollars.
And total control of the Oasis itself.
('Jump' by Van Halen plays)
Who is this "Parzival" and how the hell is he winning?
Find him.
This isn't just a game!
I'm talking about actual life-and-death stuff. The Oasis, the world's most important economic resource.
Sorrento: This is nothing less than a war for control of the future.
[Large, cascading explosion]
Welcome to the rebellion, Wade.
♪ Might as well jump ♪
♪ Go ahead and jump ♪
♪ Get in and jump ♪
Like many of you, I only came here to escape
But I found something much bigger than just myself.
Are you willing to fight?
Help us save the Oasis.